for weeks protests against Haitian
president Shabnam Maui's have paralyzed
much of the capital port-au-prince
over the weekend an uneasy calm returned
to the city with debris from road blocks
still littering the streets having a
motorbike was the most efficient way to
get around we visited the shanty town of
City Soleil the poorest slum in the city
there we met 65 year old Celine Louise
the living conditions in her
neighborhood are far from sanitary and
many of her family members are sick she
tells us she remembers a time when she
had steady work and life in the country
wasn't nearly as hard but those days are
long gone the way things are going in
the country has made things worse for
the poor we feel even more mistreated
than before there's no one here to help
us we have to look out for ourselves
there are thousands of Haitians who like
Celine have been deeply affected by the
political crisis there's an ongoing
petrol shortage fuel pumps are crowded
and with public services crippled many
people are forced to walk long distances
in search of supplies I have a wife and
children and I can't find water I've got
five dollars to buy water but I don't
know where to find it with tensions
still high the government continues to
call for a national dialogue violence is
not the best way to make your voice
heard it has a major impact on the
country's economy especially if it means
Haiti is locked down unwilling to
negotiate opposition leaders have once
again called for mass demonstrations
Haiti's political opposition has vowed
to continue to protest for as long as it
takes for the president to resign
meanwhile it's the poorest in the
country who are worst affected for them
this is a crisis with no end in sight
Manuel de pollo al Jazeera
port-au-prince